Hello
Hello, this is Adam Smith calling from Nobelprize.org,
the website of the Nobel Prize in Stockholm.
Oh, hello.
Congratulations on the award of the Nobel
Prize.
Thanks, thank you very much.
I'm just totally thrilled.
Well, first of all, you're in Brazil I gather?
That's right, I'm at a conference.
How did you hear the news of the award?
I heard the news when my wife called me at
about 7am this morning, Brazil time, because
she'd been called by the Associated Press,
and so that's how I heard.
What was your first reaction on hearing from
her that you'd been awarded the prize?
Ah, well I was just incredibly excited and
thrilled, and of course your heart races,
and you say "Oh, can this be?
Can this be?"
My life .. [unclear] .. has been recognised,
I'm incredibly fortunate.
And so I had that feeling of "Oh, what do
I do now?" because you have to decide am I
going to this meeting, do I have to get on
a plane and fly to California.
So there's lots of things that all of sudden
change when you get such exciting news and
I'm incredibly happy about the recognition
of the field, especially of all the workers
and all the scientists at many places around
the world who have contributed to the effort.
Are you going to change your programme for
the day or are you just going to go to the
conference as usual?
I can't go to the meeting right now.
It's much better to talk to people like you
and try to explain what's so exciting about
this development.
Really a great pleasure to speak to you, thank
you very much.
Thank you.
Have a good day.
Bye bye.
Bye.